hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course of his discussion of
poetry and its effects on us in Republic
book 10 Plato once again tells us that
the poets and by this he means the
producers of dramatic and epic and lyric
poetry so the the culture producers of
his time would need to be kicked out of
the city or at best they would have to
make some sort of justification for
themselves why take such an extreme
position well because Plato argues that
poetry is inherently at least the way
it's been been done in the past
corruptive to the human being and Plato
thinks of the human being as having
different parts of their soul or
personality we're not going to rehearse
the entire platonic anthropology here
but there is a higher rational part
which you can call reason or the
intellect however you want to conceive
of it and that that part does have its
pleasures its desires it is also
effective as well as cognitive and then
there are the lower parts the lower
irrational parts and in a
well-functioning person this higher part
has been developed there are no actual
conflicts within that part and if there
are if there really rational they'll
they'll think through if they have two
contradictory ideas and they're trying
to hold on to both of them they they
will realize that they have to get rid
of one of them not so for the lower
parts the lower parts can be in conflict
with themselves with each other they are
also quite often in conflict with the
higher rational part every time that you
tell yourself I shouldn't binge watch
this next show in the series Netflix or
Hulu or whatever other streaming device
that you want I should actually get up
and do some work or go to sleep it's
3:00 in the morning there is a conflict
going on between your higher rational
part which is telling you what you ought
to do and hopefully well you know
tell you what to do in such a way that
it doesn't produce conflict in the rest
of your your being and this lower part
which is saying no no let's watch
another show and so how does poetry then
relate to this how does it talk to or
affect the human being is there the
possibility for imitated art you know
music drama poetry painting all of these
sorts of things to help the higher part
of ourselves to develop it further this
is actually something that many of the
advocates of the arts do in fact say
that you know great art tends to develop
the the best things within us Plato
doesn't buy that Plato actually says
that that part of us the better part is
largely ignored unfortunately by poetry
how can that be the case doesn't Homer
for example talk about say Odysseus or
you know mentor or nest or or these
other people as having a great mind as
thinking things through doesn't don't
they depict things properly for us don't
think if us examples of great thinkers
consider movies of our own time where we
take Albert Einstein or great you know
other great theorists and mathematicians
and we put them into a movie and we
dramatize their life play to it today
well look at those things carefully do
they really portray things accurately or
do they give you a very distorted
viewpoint of what it would be to have
great talent in these rational endeavors
we might say similarly about those who
are practical reason errs not just
theoretical reasoner's do we get
depictions of proper practical reasoning
from
imitative arts or we might say
imaginative or creative arts or do we
instead get a very truncated picture
Plato would say whether he's looking at
the poetry of his own time or the
equivalents in the present that it's
really the latter that we're not getting
a good depiction of a person who makes
the right decisions who reasons in the
proper way why in part because that's
not very stimulating it's not very
exciting it doesn't appeal to our
emotions it doesn't touch us the way
that other things do so you know if we
want to see Abraham Lincoln making a
life-or-death decision affecting
thousands upon thousands of human beings
we have to have some dramatic music in
the background and have the lighting set
so that he's you know hunched over and
and then maybe a speech or something
where he he shows the anguish within his
heart whereas Plato would say maybe
that's actually not how good practical
reasoning takes place so what happens
instead the imitative arts and in
particular poetry they stimulate and
they strengthen the lower parts of
ourselves the appetites the part of
ourselves that's higher than the
appetites that he calls through most
that is concerned with courage cowardice
anger and social status or honor and
desires honor those parts get emphasized
both within the depictions of people and
in the recipients within the audience or
as he's calling them here in this
particular passage the judges the
details right the literally the critics
the people who observe the drama and
then make judgments about it and how
does it do this Plato says that we enjoy
imitation so there's a certain pleasure
involved in viewing imitations of people
within particular situations and we get
examples of how not
how we ought to behave but how we ought
to think how we ought to make decisions
how we ought to value things and
according to Plato these are actually
bad examples so he provides us with some
great discussions of this he says think
about a person who has a great loss will
that person resist and fight against his
grief or will they give in to the grief
and engage in lamentations what do we
see depicted in in poetry we see and
this is actually something that I
personally think is quite great about
the Odyssey we see grown men tough guys
crying over the loss of their comrades
and bewailing the fate that has brought
them to that feeling sad and this
affects us as the audience as well
Plato thinks that this is not good for
us he also mentions specifically anger
as something that is aroused within us
by viewing these things and we might
think in our own time about the fear of
media that we consume so he goes on and
he gives a few other examples as well he
says there we go
if you think that the very best of us
when we hear Homer or some other the
makers of tragedy imitating one of the
heroes who's in grief delivering a long
tirade in his lamentations chanting and
beating his breast we feel pleasure in
this and we abandon ourselves and
accompany the representation with
sympathy and eagerness and we praise as
an excellent poet the one who most
strongly affects us in this way we say
if it doesn't affect us then it's cold
it doesn't reach us
it doesn't take hold of us we want drama
we want music we want spectacle to make
us feel things and this ranges across
the entire spectrum from painting
to porn and everything in between it's
all about arousing the desires the
feelings the emotions in one way or
another so he says now when an
affliction comes on us we pride
ourselves if we're able to resilient ly
resist that affliction so why are we
praising the poets for representing
people in the opposite way
now that's tragedy or epic poetry
sometimes lyric poetry as well right
what about comedy he says doesn't the
same principle apply to the laughable in
comic representations or in private talk
when we're joking around with each other
do we take intense pleasure in
buffoonery x' we would blush to practice
ourselves don't we to test them as based
but we're doing the same thing as we did
with respect to the emotions that are
being driven and being aroused and being
you might say even engorged and and you
know made larger and stronger in the
process so this pleasure that we feel in
representations in imitation in our
involvement in it ends up creating
habits and mindsets so he says the part
of the soul that was forcibly restrained
and hungered for cheers and a good
crying satisfaction because it's its
nature to desire these things that's the
element in us the poet's satisfy and
delight the best element within us the
best part because it has never been
properly educated by reason or even have
it relaxes its guard over this other
part and he says in so much as this is
contemplating the wolves of others and
it's no shame to it to praise and pity
another who claims to be a good man
abandons himself to excess and his grief
it takes vicarious pleasure in it and
what happens as a result Plato uses the
metaphor of mating and reproduction here
he calls the medic or imitative arts he
tells us that what we have going on here
is actually a kind of coupling we have
the marriage or coupling or mating of a
lesser art with the lower parts of
ourselves producing things in in
consequence of that so what is the
upshot of this poetry or any other art
that we can think of in our own time
that does the same sort of thing
confronting us with characters
confronting us with their responses
their emotions their declarations about
things ruins the human person corrupts
the human person by not helping the
rational part and in flaming or
strengthening the lower parts and having
them placed into greater conflict with
the higher rational part they also
remain in conflict with themselves
because according to Plato these parts
as irrational can't actually be out of
conflict with each other
unless reason intervenes so this means
that poetry which the Greeks were using
as one of their main modes of education
both in terms of theoretical subjects
but also even more in terms of practical
subjects how we ought to live what we
ought to value how we ought to behave
why we ought to behave in that way who
we ought to listen to we can go on and
on with these topics is actually giving
us a bad basis so we would need
something else in place of it
you